etwas gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu
auch bei media markt üblich dass das
ich ja schon oftmals erklärt wie ich das
doch bitte wieder offline nehmen wir
sein video ich hoffe natürlich geht es
meiste wirklich wieder einfach in den
dann zusammen rechne also ich werde auf
haben so viele leute in irgendwelchen
foren geschrieben dann dachte ich immer
jeden fall am start noch mal ein
gut ja auch eigentlich nicht eigentlich
bisschen mehrwert überzeugen mal gucken
dicker das ist mir doch bitte erst gar
okay ich weiß übrigens leute dass das
hat und die verkaufen sicherlich auch
was da noch so drin ist lassen wir gerne
auftritte oder restposten großen mengen
nicht was ist das hier eigentlich auch
also schon ich bin mal gespannt was uns
jetzt nicht das heftigste unboxing wird
daumen nach oben da wenn ich das machen
das sieht aber schon mal benutzt aus
dann so ab an irgendwelche
ja aber ich habe zum beispiel gestern
soll oder ich weiß nicht vielleicht
im heutigen video erwartet weil ich habe
oder zumindest die das duo setzt welche
weiterverkäufer ins ausland ich weiß es
klappt es doch gar nicht werden sehen
was neues einsteiger taschen im wert von
schon mal was drin gewesen ja das trifft
logischerweise selber auch noch keinen
ansonsten könnt ihr euch wirklich auf
nicht ganz genau aber irgendwas muss ja
plan ich
die nächsten videos freuen die werden
25.000 euro dass wir wirklich geistes
kann ich euch das erzählt also ich habe
glaube ich schon echt bild und ja danke
irgendwann musste ja für zuständig sein
auch nicht so gut das finde ich immer
sind die schlimmsten die kaufen sich
dass das passiert und ich denke das sind
kann aber ich glaube es lohnt sich
vor einiger zeit mehr ins heim nacht
leute bis zu schauen das kann doch nach
trotzdem das video auf dem hauptkanal zu
fast fühlen da was rein und schicken es
jetzt einfach irgendwelche retouren die
bekomme ich würde sagen ich lasse euch
oben check up verband ab die machen echt
bringen wir starten erst mal hier mit
dann wieder zurück also das muss ich auf
mal den chartverlauf vor und dann habe
hoffentlich viel wert sind also 160
hier haben wir eine einen samsung
coole sachen und wir sehen uns haut rein
jeden fall einmal durch waschen wir
ich mit dem so einen kleinen deal
bezahlt wir schauen einfach mal oder ich
haben in den ergo mix von bosch was
backcover dass es halt bisschen lärm so
verhandelt und er hat mir dann etwas
geschick und ja das ist jetzt angekommen
bin gespannt bei den warmen temperaturen
kostet so ein denken die leute ich habe
dann haben wir hier noch mehr davon und
keine ahnung also damit kann ich mich
heute können wir ruhig mal die jacke
und wir sitzen hier um es auf zu machen
überhaupt nicht auskennen wir mal und
ausziehen oder ok ich bin wie immer ein
hier noch 11 03 keine ahnung wie sind
alex ich schaue sehr oft deine unboxing
102 euro hast also ich muss sagen die
bisschen nervös vielleicht also ich muss
videos und findest du immer sehr
wehr preise sind schon immer relativ
noch mal sagen ich bin mega projekt von
zusammen vielleicht 25 euro sagt dann
unterhaltsam wenn du sachen auspackt und
hoch und ich werde dafür sicherlich
dir dass du das machst weil viele würden
ich darüber ärgert oder auch nicht hey
nicht 102 euro bekommen hier steht sogar
machen wir weiter ich würde sagen hier
das denke ich nicht machen ich habe auch
danke übrigens dass du es unterhaltsam
noch was von mediamarkt drauf schaut
mit als nächstes haben wir hier der ist
alles was auf dich hinweisen könnte
findet wenn ich mich über etwas ärgern
noch drei jahre plus 14 99 also wir sind
schon runter gemacht hier das ab und so
das schon ein bisschen brocken aber ich
ich finde es nicht unterhaltsam ich habe
kannst du vertrauen okay machen wir es
hoffe noch in einem guten zustand ein
mich schon so oft weil irgendwelchen
jetzt auf jeden fall schon bei über 200
unboxing videos so geärgert das hab ich
panasonic rasierer und ich bin mir
mal auf 160 euro für das ganze paket ist
euro zweiter gedanke für die folie also
eigentlich sicher so wie ich das jetzt
dann halt nie hoch geladen weil die
jetzt menschheit messer haben kann also
dass du vor dir eingepackt das hat
sachen immer scheiße waren haben dass
einschätzen würde diesem gerät und
unfassbar für gebracht die ware konnte
für 160 euro ist das eigentlich echt
wir kommen gar nicht ich dachte mir
diesem ding was ihr gerade nicht sehen
gar nicht hin und her wackeln wir haben
schwer ich bin positiv gestimmt und für
vielleicht kann ich dir für ein weiteres
können diese 160 euro eigentlich schon
hier noch als nächstes aeg ja das ist da
video zur seite stehen dafür ist es aber
die die sich fragen was ich eigentlich
wieder raus das ist schon mal so vielen
im fresh ist apple watch band room habe
wichtig dass du meinen namen nicht nennt
dank derer einmal einen rasierer
von denen hatte ich schon mal ein
und bitte zensiert ich könnte es
staubsauger honka und kid also das ist
das ist von apfel band und die sponsern
eigentlich alles noch gut eingepackt
ernsthafte probleme bekommen es geht um
eine ahnung panasonic der kostet
das heute gewesen leute was geht ab ich
jetzt hier nur zubehör kostet irgendwas
ware von media markt möglich gern mal
bestimmt 70 euro schauen wir mal nach
bin gerade hier spazieren bei mir im
gruß aus bayern ich muss erst mal
zwischen 20 und 30 euro schein jahr 30
park ist dirk neben beim büro und das
was haben wir denn hier legal etf auf
vorneweg sagen ich krieg so oft solche
euro wenn es gut läuft okay und jetzt
heutige video wird gesponsert von apfel
ebay einfach das dingen 134 euro 85
nachricht oder so ähnliche nachrichten
band ich habe mir gerade auch meine
wo mir leute irgendwie dann so rest post
geht es aber weiter dann haben wir hier
apple watch an und das ganze kombiniert
wobei ich mir jetzt eigentlich nicht
noch zwei webcams einmal eine
andrehen wollen die sagen und alex ist
vorstellen kann aber amazon habe ich
mit einem armband von apfel bahn ihr
playstation webcam da habe ich mich ja
denn für 1 60 euro gefunden was trotzdem
mit 500 euro und da ist wahren wert von
könnt gerne mal die seite abchecken ich
letztens mal irgendwo gefragt auf meinem
ganz gut ist also rasierer 1 60 euro
1200 euro drin habe ich einmal
bremse auch hier mal ein auf jeden fall
zweiten kanal war das glaube ich warum
gibt es auf der absehbaren website ganz
vielleicht gemacht und seitdem nie
ist sowas überhaupt gibt und haben wir
kann man vermeiden ist ein guter start
wieder aber hier weiß jetzt was anderes
ganz viele verschiedene arm männer für
sogar noch ein preisschild 335 euro das
heute haben wir auch nicht so viele
ich habe mir mein erzähl mir gerne mal
produkte das heißt ich suche mir euch
männer und frauen ganz viele
heißt das war wahrscheinlich schon beim
mehr und klar du brauchst du echt keine
verschiedene styles lederarmbänder
das ganze hier unten in der ecke mal auf
laden keine ahnung weiter geht's mit
silikon am ende was auch immer ich habe
sorgen machen ich zensiere das alles
müssen wir jetzt gerade bei circa 86
einer nächsten webcam die hier ist von
versprochen habe ich ihn natürlich
trotz auch nicht schlecht scheint auch
mir meine ferien zum aussuchen dürfen
euro seien weiter geht's als nächstes
verarscht wie ihr sehen könnt ist alles
und die kann man halt ganz einfach
noch ungeöffnet also dinger echt mies
haben wir hier ein headset okay das
nicht zensiert natürlich sehe ich das
wechseln ich zeige euch mal wie einfach
halbzeit ist von ist einfach ein xbox
alles ist es mir wichtig nicht dass der
korrekt dass du mir geschrieben hast
das ist leute ohne dass das ganze jetzt
also hier habe ich die neue für 42 und
headset und ja keine ahnung preis steht
kollege seinen job verliert so weiter
hoffentlich nicht ins wasser fällt aber
geht es also ich arbeite so zu sagen bei
leider nicht dran sind aber noch in dem
das ist gerade wirklich ein bisschen
dann haben wir zu guter letzt ja mir tut
media markt und habe dort auch oft was
crazy was ich hier mache ihr könnt hier
ein bisschen leid das war es irgendwie
das ist sogar noch originalverpackt egal
mit den räten zu tun das meiste wird
hinten einfach auf diese knöpfe drücken
leider schon das ist jetzt leider das
ich habe wirklich keine ahnung was das
natürlich direkt wieder an den
letzte produkt aber ich glaube auch das
und ganz einfach die armbänder
ladenverkauf gebracht einiges aber auch
genau für sachen sind und wie es
teuerste einen google maps audio also
rausziehen und halten mit neuen
zustande kommen weil hier wunder ich
nicht das hat oft verschiedene gründe
mich jetzt dass das original verpackt
kombinieren ich muss sagen ich finde das
alexa von google ist das nicht gönne ich
ich denke ich könnte es organisieren dir
ist oder zumindest ganz mal aufmachen
echt nice weil neben meinen anderen
aber damit wird das denkmal nix seien
grund trage ich mir doch sehr auf die
mir auch mal kurz ein ja scheiße da
mal ein paket zusammenzustellen das wird
apple watch und dann hat man einfach mal
sie doch wunderbar aus 6 ab weil sie
hätte ich jetzt gedacht das wäre ein
sich sicher lohnen für dich mit geld
ja quasi eine ganz neue uhr am
bisschen teurer 64 eur 90 also ihr könnt
dahinter und dann sind bei mir natürlich
handgelenk und vom spaziergang bei dem
nicht so ein headset brauche ich will
jetzt schon hier sehen ich muss mir
die alarmglocken angegangen ich habe
schönen wetter wieder zurück in mein
mal schätzen irgendwie nur 40 euro kann
jetzt kurz mal sammelt das ein mal
büro wertes gedacht ich habe natürlich
geschrieben klingt eigentlich echt
zusammenrechnen aber hey das hat dich so
interessant hh können wir gerne machen
man dafür bestimmt nehmen was sagt mein
auch noch einen code für euch und zwar
krass gelohnt also die 160 euro habe ich
scanner damit 44 eur 44 ja auch nicht
ha ha für wie viel geld würdest du denn
gibt es mit alex w 15 15 prozent rabatt
auf jeden fall mehr als alles fast
so was zusammenstellen haare helle die
auf alle produkte und das geile ist
leute die immer so hh dahinter schreiben
verdreifacht für zweieinhalbfache
schlecht also leute es läuft es läuft es
aktuell ist noch bis zum 18 april spring
obwohl es eigentlich gar nicht witzig
ungefähr ist schon echt stark starke
läuft wir haben doch eigentlich jetzt
ist wenn es in ordnung geht würde ich
sale das heißt noch mal zusätzlich 20
schon fast die 160 euro drin und ich
150 euro vorschlagen falls es sie dann
leistung hätte ich nicht endlich muss
habe ich sehe hier noch einige ist also
rabatt wenn ihr glück habt gibt es also
ich sagen hätte ich nicht mit gerechnet
gefällt können wir auch mehr geld
ich hab es natürlich gehofft aber ich
ihr könnt mir gern man doch nach oben da
ausmachen plus dann den versand ja und
insgesamt 35 cent rabatt das game ab
wurde auch schon so oft enttäuscht
lassen wenn ich dem kollegen nur sagen
deswegen freut mich das natürlich ne
so weiter ich habe immer letztendlich
soll ja komm ich geb dir mal 1000 euro
leute und wir machen weiter mit dem
160 euro geschickt und er hat mir ein
also weiter ich habe jetzt gerade noch
paket zusammengestellt und ich habe echt
macht da mal was weiß nicht ob das macht
mal alles zusammengerechnet und wir
video strohleute dann würde ich sagen
kommen auf insgesamt 367 euro was auf
keine ahnung was mich da jetzt erwartet
so keine ahnung bei ich habe zum
metzger links rechtsgrund hier sagt
beispiel einmal so ein video gemacht hat
jeden fall echt ein stabiler wert ist
so weit ich das beurteilen kann ist es
mir dann amazon produkttester ware
alles realistische preise also ich habe
zukommen lassen und er hat danach so rum
jetzt nie die höchsten wie immer habe
geheult und alex kannst dass du dich